You all probably know by now that when channels
like mine, shows like mine talk about stories
like the one I'm about to talk about, we get
a D. monetized and penalized on YouTube and
Facebook.
But what has been captured on video over the
last 24 to 48 hours is too insane.
And it's too important not to tell you about
it and to show it to you.
So let's dig right into it.
First of all, New York Police Department officers
have been caught on video beating a cyclist
with batons as he tries to cross the street.
The cyclist seems to be crossing his bike
while wearing a helmet at a crosswalk, mind
you.
Not even jaywalking.
And multiple officers are just beating the
crap out of him.
And it looks like they're beating the cyclist
on the upper leg.
Eventually, the cyclist is forced off of his
bike bike before the video ends.
We don't know exactly what led up to it, but
at this point in the video, this is not an
individual that is resisting.
And there are multiple officers beating him
with batons.
And this led to Congresswoman Alexandrea Castillo
Cortez to tweet, quote, horrifying.
You start with the tiny possibility that two
officers may be walking over to de-escalate
the abusive one.
Instead, they join in beating a man trying
to get out of traffic.
This isn't a problem of bad apples or incidents.
This is an institutional and systemic crisis.
And the reason I'm picking this incident to
talk about is that Congresswoman AOSIS response
mirrors exactly what I've been talking about
all week when she says this isn't a problem
of bad apples or incidents.
This is an institutional and systemic crisis.
When I did my first commentary about the protests
and the civil unrest that we're experiencing
on the Monday show, that was the main point
that I tried to make.
There were really two points.
Point one, was anybody claiming some grand
unifying theory about this?
This is all about capitalism.
This is all about race.
This is all about police brutality.
It's not.
So any grand unifying theory that focuses
on one element is destined to be to fall short.
But maybe most importantly, that the individual
incidents may give us a window into the systemic
problems, a lens, a suggestion.
But really, we need to be talking about the
systemic aspects that are plaguing our country.
And the debate over good and bad police doesn't
actually address the systemic issues that
are at the heart of much of what is going
on.
In another video from North Carolina, police
likewise were filmed in this video.
They are destroying elements of medical for
lack of a better term, a sort of medical station
that had some medics and basic first aid supplies
and a lot of bottled water.
You can see in this video police standing
above a ton of destroyed and poured out bottled
water there in Asheville, North Carolina.
A report said that police hit some of the
medics with their shields and knocked people
to the ground.
And this is, again, you know, we can talk
about individuals, but there is something
particularly nefarious in this instance because
of the principal called medical neutrality.
So we have norms that are being ignored.
We've talked about you don't go after press
and we've seen press attacked both by some
protesters and by police in different places
over the last week.
But now we're talking about the principle
of medical neutrality in any conflict.
You do not go after anybody who is providing
medical services.
You have a protest.
You have police.
Most protesters are peaceful.
Most police are good.
There is some scuffle.
You do not pull the medical people into it.
Police may try to argue, well, you know, if
the medical people weren't there, the protesters
would be less brazen and aggressive.
No.
At the international level, going after the
medical, going after medical is a violation
of the Geneva Convention.
These are, of course, domestic protests.
We're talking about domestic law enforcement.
The Geneva Conventions don't apply.
But if this conflict, instead of being between
protesters and looters or police and protesters
or police and looters or whatever, if this
were a conflict between two countries and
the Geneva Convention rules applied, either
side destroying medical elements would be
a violation of the Geneva Convention.
So we've got attacks on media.
People from the press hit with rubber bullets,
sprayed, hit with shields, almost everything
we've seen over the last seven days.
The point of this segment is not let's pick
on police or particular police any more than
I pick on individual protesters.
Most protesters are peaceful.
Protesters are peaceful.
The ones that aren't peaceful are really not
protesters.
They're.
They're doing other things.
They're looters, they're instigators, insiders,
whatever provocateurs.
Police are mostly doing the right thing.
And we have shows of support and kneeling
and singing and everything with police from
all over the country.
But this is about the bigger picture.
We have a horrible situation going on.
Much of it because of protests, because of
police brutality.
And we are seeing everything from cyclists
beaten to a medical station destroyed to a
president saying, hey, here's an idea for
how to solve the protests and unrest caused
by police brutality.
Let's encourage more brutality against protesters.
Everything we are seeing at a systemic level
is the opposite of what we need.
Thankfully, at the individual level, many
police departments have been great.
Many individual officers have been great.
We've seen protesters bringing water to police.
We've seen police joining protesters in all
of this stuff.
But unless the systems are changed, nothing
will change.
And so later on today, a lot of people on
my streams this week and via email and saying,
David, can you explain how to deal with police
brutality?
And essentially none of it has to do with
the individual.
It is all systemic changes.
And I'm going to outline them for you a little
bit later on in the program